remember when the t-rex took over san
diego how about the iconic last words of
robert muldoon get your remote handy
because these are the most paused
moments in the jurassic park franchise
as popular and successful as the theme
park in jurassic world is before all the
dinosaurs get loose at least it's not
exactly what jon hammond originally had
in mind whereas the first iteration of
jurassic park was basically a
prehistoric zoo jurassic world is a
full-fledged amusement park with all the
bells whistles and merchandise tie-ins
one might expect much like main street
usa at walt disney world's magic kingdom
jurassic world has its own main street
with real world franchise locations
there's a ben jerry's ice cream shop a
dave and buster's arcade and enough
shopping outlets to qualify as a mall
one notable restaurant you might have
spotted is jimmy buffett's
margaritaville the tropical casual
dining experience based off of the
namesake singer's hit song
what you may not have noticed however is
a cameo from the cheeseburger in
paradise singer himself during the
sequence in which the pteranodons are
terrorizing everyone in sight buffett
has his priorities in order making a
valiant effort to protect his margaritas
as everyone else runs for dear life
according to yahoo buffett's cameo
appearance was a result of his longtime
friendship with jurassic world producer
frank marshall buffett and his coral
reefer band even performed some of their
signature jams with marshall and chris
pratt at the jurassic world premiere
after party
although these moments aren't in any
particular order it's only appropriate
that this one comes in the number two
spot dr alan grant dr ian malcolm tim
murphy lex murphy and donald gennaro are
returning in the automated ford
explorers as dennis nedry makes his big
escape to the docks it's night time it's
raining and their suvs just so happen to
be passing by the tyrannosaurus paddock
when nedry's program executes shutting
down power to the vehicles and the high
voltage security fences meant to keep
the dinosaurs and guests from mingling
suddenly that goat the control room used
to goad the t-rex out with earlier stops
bleeding
we see that iconic shot of the rippling
water glasses courtesy of the gargantuan
steps of the prehistoric tyrant the
t-rex's steps what's remaining from the
goat carcass drops on the vehicle and a
cowardly donald makes a run for the
bathroom leaving the kids
behind he left the tyrannosaurus breaks
containment as they tend to do and goes
after the last thing it's all moving
luckily allen gets her attention with a
road flare and ian follows suit giving
the former a chance to rescue the kids
when the t-rex chases ian into the
bathroom it completely falls apart
leaving only poor donald sitting there
atop a toilet seconds away from being
snapped up in her jaws if you look
closely you'll see that the lawyer was
still wearing his pants and was only
using the bathroom for cover much to
everyone's relief except donald's that
is
there are few things dumber than
choosing to travel to the
dinosaur-infested island of isla sorna
and one of them is snatching up an
infant tyrannosaurus rex and trying to
treat it like a wounded puppy well in
the lost world jurassic park animal
behavior scientist dr sarah harding and
photographer nickman owen do both after
the team releases several captive dinos
to wreak havoc on the injen base camp
nick nabs a baby t-rex with a broken leg
and convinces sarah to help him bring it
to their mobile lab for treatment they
tend to its wounds despite ian's
protests and predictably find themselves
face to face with two very concerned
parents
mommy's very angry
the team tries to appease the angry
couple by returning their baby but it's
too little too late the two combine
their efforts to push the rv off a cliff
leaving ian sarah and nick hanging the
three eventually make it back alive
thanks to eddie's noble sacrifice and
injen's convenient timing but not before
a nearly 10 minute long sequence full of
intense death-defying moments
if you're crazy enough to agree to
disable jurassic park's security systems
in order to steal fertilized dinosaur
embryos from their labs there's a good
chance you might not make it back home
alive such is the case with dennis nedry
the bumbling antagonist of the series
first entry after retrieving that
precious dino dna dennis makes his not
so great escape in the pouring rain only
to lose his way and crash his jeep into
the mud he tries to use a metal cable to
free the car but ends up taking a tumble
down a hill and losing his glasses in
the process once he gains his bearings
he finds himself face to face with a not
so friendly dilophosaurus rather than
run dennis tries to bargain with the
creature eventually throwing a stick for
it to fetch like a dog
and no wonder you're extinct
i'm gonna run you over when i come back
down
unlike a dog however the dilophosaurus
opens her neck frill and spits venom in
dennis's face before finally killing him
while the dilophosaurus wasn't exactly
able to spit such sticky venom in real
life the scene makes for one of the
highlights of the first film and a
satisfying bit of comeuppance for such a
loathsome villain
when lovable scamps zack and grey
mitchell get the chance to ditch their
chaperone zara and finally get the
chance to see something cool it takes
jurassic world's mosasaurus a giant
aquatic reptile from the late cretaceous
period to get their attention the boys
head to an enclosure reminiscent of the
orca attractions at sea world only this
time instead of a wetsuit clad trainer
feeding shamu a fish by hand they're
feeding a massive once extinct creature
an entire great white shark with a crane
the mosasaurus gobbles up the shark in a
single bite drenching zach gray and
everyone else sitting in the splash zone
feeding the modern ocean's alpha
predator to the mossasaurus like a
sardine straight out of a can is meant
to demonstrate its sheer size and
strength beyond just making it look big
with special effects it's also a nod to
one of the creative minds that launched
the jurassic park franchise director
steven spielberg who helmed jurassic
park and the lost world and rose to fame
after directing the shark thriller jaws
the shark being fed to the mosasaurus
happens to be trussed up similarly to
the falsely accused tiger shark that was
very much not the source of the town's
problems in the first jaws films the
mosasaurus makes another appearance to
zach and grey later on albeit under less
entertaining circumstances when the
beast makes dessert out of zera and some
pteranodons so much for adult
supervision
under the direction of john hammond's
usurping nephew peter ludlow injen's big
plan in the lost world is to capture a
bunch of the dinosaurs on isla sorna and
bring them to a facility in san diego
for public exhibition naturally
everything works out perfectly no one is
hurt and they all go on to live happy
and fulfilling lives
except not things go wrong and people
are hurt
after managing to capture the male
tyrannosaurus and load him onto a cargo
ship injen sets about sailing back to
the mainland with the dinosaur in tow
unfortunately things don't go wrong soon
enough as the ship carrying papa t-rex
actually manages to make it all the way
to port before promptly crashing and
releasing him from his cage what follows
is carnage on a level mother nature
never intended the entire ending
sequence of the lost world defies belief
for more than one reason not only is an
angry dinosaur rampaging through a major
urban center but younger viewers might
find it preposterous that gas was ever
1.15 cents for regular 87 octane
unleaded speaking of the t-rex's tear
through san diego one moment during the
chaotic climax of the lost world sees
the carnivore chase a city bus into a
blockbuster video remember blockbuster
that place where people used to rent
movies back when they had to be manually
rewound anyway when bus 967 takes a cue
from netflix and puts blockbuster out of
business a quick click of the pause
button reveals a few posters for the
movies you might not be able to check
out in real life there's a jack and the
beanstalks starring robin williams a
reference to francis ford coppola's jack
a film in which williams portrayed a 10
year old child with a rapid aging
disorder if you're a surfing fan don't
miss tsunami sunrise which looks like
what would happen if tom hanks starred
in point break finally for the english
teachers in the audience there's an
adaptation of shakespeare's classic
tragedy king lear starring none other
than the terminator himself arnold
schwarzenegger it's just a shame that
none of the blockbuster customers got to
enjoy their movie night you know on
account of the rampaging dinosaur
the climactic final showdown right
before the end of the first jurassic
park movie takes place in the park's
visitor center as tim and lex sit down
to dinner having finally returned to
safety by allen lex starts shaking so
hard her lime jello nearly falls off her
spoon she sees the shadow of a
velociraptor on the wall behind her
brother and the two take refuge in the
kitchen with the raptors in pursuit
after they managed to trap one in the
walk-in cooler they reunite with dr alan
grant and dr ellie sadler before heading
for the control room just because the
security system is rebooted and the
doors are locked it doesn't mean a
velociraptor is going to give up however
raptor crashes through the window and
follows them through the ventilation
system to the lobby and after a quick
struggle all four humans and the
dinosaur find themselves dangling from a
skeleton suspended from the ceiling
after everyone comes crashing down it
looks like the end for our brave heroes
things are looking bleak with one raptor
about to pounce but the t-rex shows up
and snatches the much smaller dino up in
its jaws the humans look on in amazement
as they realize their lies have just
been saved by the same massive carnivore
that had terrorized them so recently
allen and company beat feet as the
second raptor retaliates but it's no
match for the tyrannosaurus having
established dominance the t-rex does
what comes naturally it roars a mighty
roar knocking the banner loose and
giving us the picture perfect shot
at the onset of jurassic park 3 dr alan
grant is in desperate need of funding to
continue his research on velociraptors
against his better judgment he agrees to
give a rich couple and their shady
associates an aerial tour of isla sorna
only to find himself shanghaied into
what was actually a rescue mission all
along here we go again the third
installment in the original jurassic
park trilogy introduces viewers to one
of many challengers to the tyrannosaurus
rex's throne the spinosaurus when alan
wakes up from his involuntary nap
courtesy of armed thug cooper he finds
that not only has the plane landed but
his fellow passengers have made enough
noise to lead the fearsome predator
directly to them karma quickly comes for
cooper as he's left behind when the
group scrambles to get back on the plane
as they're about to take off a
spinosaurus jumps out and devours cooper
damaging the plane in the process and
forcing a crash landing just when they
think they've escaped they find
themselves face to face with the
tyrannosaurus who engages the
spinosaurus in a battle to the death the
group is forced to watch as survival of
the fittest plays out right in front of
them spinosaurus one t-rex zero
in jurassic park having not heard from
alan tim and lex the remaining survivors
work on getting the park systems back
online chief engineer ray arnold sets
about rebooting every device on the
island but has to head to a maintenance
shed to complete the process when he
doesn't return dr ellie sappler and game
warden robert muldoon head out to assess
the situation unfortunately they find
the rebooting process has released the
velociraptors from their nearby
enclosure their solution is simple
robert will distract the velociraptors
who are pack hunters by nature while
ellie turns the power back on the only
problem one of the raptors peels off
after ellie leaving two for robert to
handle ellie is attacked by the third
raptor after flipping the switch but
manages to hobble her way back out to
the jeep robert meanwhile is tracking
one of the raptors shotgun in hand but
as alan warned earlier in the film the
attack doesn't come from a head it comes
from the side as robert stalks one of
the velociraptors the other one flanks
him and prepares for an ambush thinking
he's outsmarted the raptor he's after by
using his hat as a decoy robert
eventually realizes he's the one who's
fallen into a trap then come those
famous last words
clever girl
much like the lost world jurassic world
fallen kingdom centers on capturing
dinosaurs running wild on an island this
time owen grady and claire deering head
to the ruins of the once prosperous
jurassic world in an attempt to save the
dinosaurs there from an active volcano
that threatens re-extinction
despite being assured by ellie mills the
assistant to jon hammond's former
partner sir benjamin lockwood that the
dinos would be transferred to a new
island sanctuary mills secretly intends
to auction each one off to the highest
bidder however as usual things don't go
as planned for the bad guys despite
being left for dead owen and claire
survive stowing away on the transport
ship when they're discovered at the
lockwood estate they escape captivity
with the help of a hard-headed
pachycephalosaurus which owen sets loose
in the auction chamber while the crown
jewel the indoraptor is on display
everything goes bananas and the caged
dinosaurs are about to be killed by
poison gas leaving owen and claire with
the terrible choice of letting them die
or releasing them to go roam the united
states fortunately or maybe
unfortunately macy the clone of
lockwood's deceased daughter makes the
decision for them setting the animals
free and quite possibly dooming the west
coast to annihilation by dinosaurs in
the movie's denumon montage as dr ian
malcolm testifies before congress we see
a tyrannosaurus rex approach a zoo and
have an intense stare down with a lion
with the animals showing off their
mightiest roars to each other
unfortunately for the lion though this
doesn't exactly seem like an even
match-up
at the climax of jurassic world owen
grady has managed to reconnect with blue
and the other velociraptors
re-establishing himself as the alpha of
the pack when the indominus rex comes
along and figures out what's up she is
not happy and attacks blue if the
loyalty of the remaining velociraptors
was ever in doubt the indominus
attacking one of their own makes the
sides very clear owen sticks them on the
indominus and tries to lead claire zack
and grey to safety but the larger
dinosaur outmatches the two raptors rey
says they need more teeth which gives
claire the insane yet ultimately
brilliant idea to add the tyrannosaurus
rex into the mix against his better
judgment lowry cruthers the last
employee left in the control room
releases the t-rex and claire leads it
into battle with flares mirroring the
iconic t-rex attack scene from the
original jurassic park the indominus is
getting the better of the tyrannosaurus
until blue gains a second wind and
re-enters the fray fighting alongside
the t-rex as the tide turns the battle
shifts away from the visitor center and
the indominus finds itself backed up
against the edge of the lagoon unwilling
to yield any more ground it lets out a
massive roar which the t-rex and blue
echo then player 4 enters the game the
mosasaurus lunges out of the lagoon
grabs the indominus by the throat in its
massive jaws and drags it down
underwater more teeth indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]